what do you guys think uh cat and
Chappell or what anything Chappell
what's the biggest you've ever been I've
been around cheerleaders so well I'm
saying what's the biggest you've ever
been though like it though biggest I've
ever in fat before I've been fat I just
I mean I've always been thick thick but
I've never been like fat you know chin
was almost 300 pounds almost 300 pounds
wait why five really shorter - are you
serious yeah picture there's Piggy's
problem on picture it looks like you owe
them it's the same Hawkins dance
it looks like I'm a ventriloquist I'm
not even kidding
are you serious I'm serious bring that
[ __ ] up we're going to see this a sad
yeah James - he's fine my old pictures
that crazy worked long and hard you been
fat I never been fat man I wait when I
was a child I was like in the seven
hundred percent overweight though I was
boring I was like yeah I was like 13
pound baby oh [ __ ] you want to be thick
as a baby
I'm one like biggest baby in like our
county or whatever for first when I was
born
damn I won the biggest baby in our
county look for when I was born thanks
dude they already baby book and
everything but that's and how scared of
that little girl see first of all that
girl looks edible [ __ ] and second of all
how is your name the only thing you
can't even find laughs why are you
wearing a vest like that oh he's a
Maitre D' obviously but when you are if
you are a hundred percent Asian which
I'm assuming chin is you have to Maitre
D' is like one of the it's like a
popular attire what's up with your pants
those are janko's members
gingka I can tell what what it was yeah
she looks scared do bring [ __ ] looks
like a guy who fixes video game fishing
but claims he has another job too
how great that picture Ginga chin how to
lose the weight I tried everything even
high school I tried slim fast universe
slim fast yeah it was so embarrassing so
I do you know get like foil to cover it
because I didn't want people to see I
was really little bags that tried
everything if I finally like after just
not eating that Bush seemed to work yeah
you try just fast I don't use many carbs
that's the goal right just don't eat as
much while dude and how did you lose the
[Laughter]
how do you lose now Friar Tuck wedding
attire he went out of style after a
while the style after Robin Hood is this
in Texas now this is here in Orange bro
you look like deep Friar Tuck that an
Asian dad is trying to [ __ ] get into
a wedding okay it's so true I did look
like a girl like a beautiful lady thank
you you shouldn't think down about
yourself beautiful lady own that [ __ ]
but definitely you got that straight up
F talk vide son you know that fart easy
dog you everything about sumo like to
actually do it yeah no you're gonna went
that way you know what do you even
Brendon when it up into fighting each
other in some international I'm still
going on still popping they still do it
all wanna know if it's still going on
right now well I doubt it's nobody it's
still poppin who's the Yokozuna right
now look it up brother marry Yokozuna
and
WUF yeah I was Yokozuna really he's a
giant Asian dude big dude who's the
current Yokozuna only two active
Yokozuna now remain in professional sumo
wrestling
kissing nuts all they do is eat white
rice and nap and then the cream and
they're legends where when they die at a
young age mint yeah oh you see that's a
big this would be it's a big heart
yeah so who's gonna die man we got to
figure it out
[Laughter]
[Music]